my name is Jamie rivadeneira I'm the
owner of Japan away i'm also the curator
for the Hello Kitty exhibition at the
Japanese American National Museum
I was about five years old when I first
saw hello kitty um I think it's just
very cute and it has like a lot of
integrity and it's just very tiny but
there's so many details I just naturally
liked it if you liked it as a kid you
can like it as an adult and there's more
products available for adults now and
that's what my store focus is on cute
stuff for adults write down all the the
words of all the things you like so you
write down all these things and so my
things were like Hello Kitty and cute
things in Japan and like all these
things and it kind of forms a picture in
your head so that's where Japan lak me
from
a bunch of artists that are in the show
too um so they would just come in and
buy hello kitty and you know that's how
I got to know them I really liked like
the giant stuff so that's like the Hello
Kitty tokidoki Egyptian hello kitty is
like a really large statue that we had
made um for the show and then like the
Colin Christian piece is like a really
big anime girl like but she's hello
kitty so um I mean I really like those
Gary baseman's really cool and buff
monster so it's really like all my
favorite artists
my name is anything Sewell I'm a visual
artist from when excited